good afternoon everyone thank you so
much for tuning into my webinar as part
of this conference my name is Jessica ma
I'm an assistant professor at the Albert
Einstein College of Medicine here in the
Bronx in New York the title of my talk
is investigating tissue-specific
networks of cancer causing mutations and
I'd like to thank you for for tuning in
and please encourage you to submit
questions as we go along there's a
question and answer box that you can use
and I'll be keeping track of those
questions as we come as they come in and
if there's time I'll deal with them as
we go along and if not I will spend some
time at the end going over those
questions so let me just get started
with this presentation and the starting
point from my seminar is to step back
and consider a fact that we're all aware
of and that's that there's a huge amount
of cellular diversity that exists in the
human body so we know that the human
body consists of over 200 highly
specialized cell types and we look when
we look at these cells in terms of their
morphology in terms of turnover rates
structural properties etc etc there's
clearly a lot of differences between
different cells that come that exist in
the human body now what's remarkable is
when we step back and consider that
virtually all of your cell types share
the same genome so that the diversity
that we can see even at the resolution
of the naked eye is being driven by
epigenetic and transcription factor
regulatory programs so when we think
about as cell types unique properties
these are regulated by it's largely
transcriptional program so we look to
the gene expression profiles that make
up a specific cell types unique
properties so when we can also step back
and think about cancer as a systems
level disease now i'm a bit biased
coming from a systems biology department
we tend to think of cells and diseases
in terms of how they affect the human
body as a system so in this day and age
it's important to acknowledge that
cancer is actually a broad spectrum of
diseases but what are the unifying facts
of cancer is that it's fundamentally
unregulated so grow okay and when you
think about the human body as a system
what we actually mean is you can think
about different cell types being
perturbed in the presence of this
unregulated cell growth and in the
presence of these perturbations some
tissues go on to develop cancer and some
tissues do not so when we step back and
think about it trimmers actually arrives
in a highly tissue specific manner and
in this case it's important to
distinguish that we're talking about the
primary tumor arising but even when we
consider metastasis often specific
tumors also metastasized in a highly
tissue specific specific manner excuse
me and breast cancer is a good example
okay breast cancer all found
metastasized to the brain and to the
boring but what I wanted to emphasize is
that in this talk with purely talking
about primary tumors so a place to a
good a good area to think about a cancer
is in terms of germline mutations now we
know that generally mutations predispose
cells to cancer and just so we're all on
the same page a germline mutation is
defined as any change or variation in a
gene that's occurring in a reproductive
cells whether it be an egg or sperm cell
and what's most important is that it's
incorporated in the DNA
single cell type in the offspring in
other words the germline mutation is
transmitted to the next generation so
based on all our work and cats our
research we know about 80 genes that
have germline mutations that predispose
to different types of cancer and out of
all the cancer genes that we know about
Owen only about twenty percent have
germline mutations and about ten percent
sure both somatic and German mutations
so the majority of mutations that affect
cancer or Claus cancer are actually
occurring in the soma the somatic tissue
but what's really interesting to
consider is that generally mutations are
present in every single cell type of the
body so one good example to think of
that our butt is weet germline mutations
that occur in the breast cancer gene
Braca one okay now we all know that
Braco one is linked to hereditary breast
and ovarian cancers and in normal
healthy tissue rakha one functions as
the tumor suppressor gene it's actually
critically involved in repairing DNA
double-stranded breaks and it's also
involved in this match repair now Braca
one is well known in terms of cancer in
intense research because you tations in
breck alone account for eighty to ninety
percent of hereditary breast and ovarian
cancers and it's actually also involved
in over fifty percent of inherited
breast cancers now what's really
interesting to consider is that you've
got a patient who has a germline
mutation in brachle one and the
predisposed to develop cancer in the
breast and in the ovaries but when you
think about the other tissues that these
are unaffected and from our perspective
you could consider them to be cancer
resistant whereas breast and ovarian
tissue are cancer susceptible
and so what is it that distinguishes the
breast and ovarian and other tissues
from being affected by the germline
mutation if you think of perturbing the
system every single tissue in the system
is perturbed due to the presence of the
bracket one mutation howevers
perturbation results in the development
of a tumor only in the breast and
ovarian tissues and when we consider
even bought what's going on with black
and one it's important to note that
bracket one is highly expressed in many
different kinds of cell types both at
the level of transcription and also at
the level of proteins so what we want to
ask ourselves to try and answer this
question is how is Bracken 1 regulated
in a normal setting in a cancer-free
setting in different tissues okay as I
mentioned we do detect high levels of
brokol 1 and different tissues and this
indicates that rock or one is an
important gene product in multiple cell
types so as we talked about before each
tissue and the human body is governed by
its own tissue specific regulatory
networks they share the same genome and
the differences that we see from tissue
to tissue are explained by changes in
gene expression and the wider regulatory
networks that control these cells
properties so what we want to do using
back on one as our example is look in
normal tissue to understand how tissue
specific differences affect a cell's
ability to buffer in the event of a
germline mutation occurring in bracket
one so what we're trying to do then is
to actually reconstruct and analyze
tissue specific gene networks to
determine whether there are hints of
local network changes that can explain
the susceptibility or resistance to
cancer that we observe
in the susceptible tissues okay the hot
the whole goal of this is to understand
why some tissues are able to tolerate
germline mutations better than others
and we're using genes with germline
mutations as a test case because they're
present in every single cell type of the
human body so just to step through the
analysis that we've done the research
that we've done this is the flowchart of
our work so first of all and I'm going
to go through each of these steps in
more detail but the goal of our work was
to first of all start with a subset of
genes where we know that they cause
cancer and through germline mutations we
then wanted to identify which of these
genes that are associated with germline
mutations have tumors that are highly
tissue-specific we want then wanted to
look at gene expression across the
tissue atlas to understand how these
genes are being expressed differentially
between different tissues and then what
we've done is to go ahead and both
understand what these different classes
of genes are doing but more importantly
construct different types of gene
networks and in this case we've used
protein-protein interaction networks and
transcription factor networks and
finally we look at functionally at how
these may shed insight into the
buffering capability of these cats are
susceptible and cancer resistant tissues
okay so first of all what we needed to
do was identify a set of cancer genes
with Jem I mutations and the resource
that we turned to was the cancer gene
census now this is an amazing catalog of
genes that genes in a repository that's
been hosted through the sanger center
these genes have all been identified as
having a causal role in cancer and the
census contains all these cancer genes
they make up about one percent of all
human gene
and basically there's a wealth of
genetic information that's been reported
from the literature that's captured in
this gene census so if you're interested
in having a look at how I'd highly
recommend this as a resource I'm from
this we've we've been able to extract
about 80 different genes that are linked
with germline mutations that cause
cancer and that number has changed with
regular updates from the resource so now
that we have our set of germline
mutation of genes with germline
mutations it's important to step back
and understand that just because a gene
has a mutation doesn't mean that you'll
automatically definitely get cancer okay
and to explain this idea further there's
a concept in genetics related to
penetrance and that this is the idea in
this context that not all tissues
carrying the journal and the same driver
mutation will develop cancer and in fact
what we see is that some German
mutations their associated cancers that
a highly tissue-specific like vodka one
while others affect issues more
ubiquitously meaning that a lot of
different tissue classes are affected
with the same germline mutation so in
this context we define tissue-specific
penetrance as the property of observing
a large number of tumors associated with
germline mutations that are occurring in
genes in one or two tissue groups and so
obviously that one or two is an
arbitrary definition but the point that
we want to get across is that this is a
highly tissue restricted subset okay and
to get that information and to actually
assess tissue-specific penetrance the
resource that we've turned to is to use
cosmic which stands for the catalog of
somatic mutations in cancer now this is
also another resource that's hosted by
Samuel it contains a wide array of
genetic information on
samples that have been collected in the
literature and this is information it's
worth pointing out pertains to both
germline and somatic mutations despite
the somatic in the in the the catalogs
name so basically with cosmic for every
every gene that's listed you can look at
the mutations as they are reported in
about 40 standardized tissue categories
so you can get tissue specific
information on specific mutations that
are reported in specific genes so for
instance you can say for GNex how many
samples have this mutation that we know
about in the current literature and how
many of those samples occur in a
specific to shoot their tissue why okay
and so just to give you a demonstration
of that we have the tissue specific
profile for p53 now we all know p53 is a
very important gene in cancer genetics
and hear what I'm showing you is the
tissue percentage distribution the p53
in cosmic okay and it's really hard to
see the labels on the x-axis I apologize
for that but basically these are the
different tissue categories so for
instance and I'm afraid you're just
going to have to believe me um but one
of these bars corresponds to a lung
breast ovary brain CNS and the height of
the bar reflects the percentage of
samples out of all the samples that have
p53 mutations that are specific or
reported in that particular tissue class
so the point of this profile or this
graph is to show you that for p53 it's
actually quite scattered in terms of the
tissues where mutations in p53 have been
reported and
there's no surprise in terms of
understanding what p53 does in cancer
now it may be hard to see but hopefully
you can see they're also the red line
that is going across that chart and
basically that represents the tissue me
so in cosmic different tissue classes
have different numbers absolute numbers
represented in the catalog and this
obviously reflects the fact that some
tissues are easier to profile than
others it's easier to get a biopsy from
the breast of a long rather than you
know an i or of the brain for instance
and so in doing our calculation and
trying to figure out which genes the
tissue-specific we didn't want to be
biased by sampling that was present in
cosmic so what we've done to determine
whether a gene is tissue specific in
terms of penetrance is we've taken those
genes that have a tissues percentage
that's greater than the tissue-specific
mean in one or two different tissue
groups and so to help elucidate that
concept let me show you the
tissue-specific penetrance profile for
fractal one okay so in this case what
we've got now is the same kind of
profile we're looking at the same tissue
categories that are represented in close
neck and you can see automatically that
Braca one is highly tissue-specific for
the breast which is the left and the
ovary which is sort of in the center of
the graph you can see there's really
high bars compared to all the other
tissue specific categories so another
thing to note is that the next highest
bar that's not label is actually the
long so this may not be such as
but what is interesting is that you can
see the tissue mean for the loan is
actually generally quite high and I
think that reflects the fact that there
is a large percentage of tumors in the
cosmic database that are a long tissue
so what we've done just to repeat is to
count the number of tissues associated
with a gene where the tissue percentage
is higher than that is you mean and that
forms our definition of a highly
tissue-specific penetrant gene and so
just to look at this now what we see is
that for the 70-80 genes with germline
mutations most of these germline
mutations are actually associated with
tissue-specific tumors and so what we've
got here in this graph is basically a
histogram where we're counting the
number of genes with germline mutations
and the number of tissues a genius
mutated in okay and so here you can see
some of the typical cancer genes that
are represented such as ATM Braca one
bracket to egfr a pc which is associated
color until katse hrs p53 that's all the
way at the end the high end of the
number of tissues and we have two genes
ddb to and tsc2 which we didn't have
data on that's why there's zero tissues
is not enough data there so basically
what we've done is we've drawn a line
and I wish you guys could see my mouse
pointer but what we've done is drawn a
line between two and three and we've
called everything to the left of that
line tissue-specific and everything to
the right ubiquitous okay now when we
think about how these genes are
operating in different cell types in the
human body we have to consider the level
with gene expression of these genes as
well we know that there's a germline
at the present in every single spell and
only a subset of those tissues are
susceptible to cancer so when you
consider genes that are highly expressed
in a wide range of tissues we have to
ask the question of how resistance is
achieved in some tissues but not others
so to go back to our bracket one example
we can imagine that we know from breca
one that the breast and ovarian tissues
are not resistant to cancer and yet it's
we can consume for in terms of neural
cells on brain cells the the incidence
of primary events of cancer is very low
okay but yet when we consider transcript
availability and levels of expression we
we see high levels of expression across
different cell types so it's not a
simple situation of a gene is mutated in
a specific tissue and therefore the
level of gene expression is decreased
it's not a dosage effective in the
absence of the ability to produce this
transcript that the downstream effects
lead to tumor Genesis okay so in order
to look at gene expression in a
tissue-specific manner with turn to a
resource that's been made available by
the factor of five consortium that's
being led at rican the rican ohmic
science center in yokohama in japan so
the goal of the plaintiff consortium was
to build a complete promoter map to
uncover the transcriptional regulatory
networks that define every humans
outside and these guys have created a
really great resource that will be
published and released soon that this
resource represents a tissue-specific
atlas that covers over a thousand human
primary tissues and cell lines that have
collected from all over the world and so
underlying this atlas is the healer
scope cage technology and basically what
this is it's a technology that allows
one to capture promoter usage and so
this technology uses capped analysis of
gene expression and this is a single
molecule sequencing technology there's
no amplification step involved it's
possible to start with very small
amounts of RNA and the idea is that for
each transcript this technology
sequences the five prime cap of the mRNA
so in this way the technology is
quantitative we can count the number of
tags and get a surrogate measure for how
expressed gene is but more ago we can
actually also identify where the
transcription start site is occurring
and in this way we can get a sense for
how promoters are being used across the
genome for different cell types so what
we've done then is to take the gene
expression data from the fan of five
resource and look at the expression of
our genes with germline mutations across
different tissues and the kind of
situation that we want to distinguish
from our genes that are tisha specific
in their gene expression from genes that
have a ubiquitous profile and here are
taken two genes to highlight what I mean
on the Left we see the gene expression
profile for olk olk is a tissue-specific
it's it's a gene that affects tumors in
a tissue-specific manner it's
responsible for a neuroblastoma and as
you can see from the graph it has a
highly tissue specific profile meaning
that the majority of g
genes are actually literally expressed
sorry the majority of tissues we see low
expression with some outliers towards
the end okay and for bracket to what we
see in contrast to the profile is this
has a much more ubiquitous expression
because we see multiple different states
as there's quite a broad expression
distribution meaning that there are
multiple different tissue classes where
we see different levels of a bracketed
expression so when you think about this
I think in a second all right so what
we've done then is to synthesize these
two concepts are related to tissue
specificity in terms of penetrants and
tissue specificity in terms of gene
expression and we've created a
classification for the genes for Gen Y
mutations and we've distinguished three
different classes that are interests and
the first class represents those genes
that have a mutation causing tumors in a
tissue-specific manner and where the
gene is expressed only in that tissue
okay so we can imagine the the direct
link between a gene that causes a tumor
in a specific tissue and it's also
expressed highly expressed in that
particular tissue we can also consider a
second class wear a jean with a mutation
causes the tumors because in a highly
tissue quiet manner in other words it
affects lots of different tissue classes
and it's also expressed in a lot of
different tissue classes as well and
finally our third class which to us is
the most interesting class because it
represents the genes that have mutations
that cause tumors in a specific tissue
and are also expressed ubiquitously so
like the situation with bracket
one where we know that the tissues that
are susceptible to cancer a highly
tissue-specific and restricted to the
breasts and ovaries and yet we see
expression across a lot of different
kinds of cells or cell types so these
are the ones we actually want to focus
on and out of our 70 or 80 genes this is
the distribution of counts in terms of
how they fall in the different classes
that were delineated and I'll go into
more detail in a few slides time in
terms of what those genes actually are
but first of all I just want to go into
a little bit more detail in terms of how
we distinguished between tissue-specific
and ubiquitous gene expression okay now
this is an interesting problem from a
bioinformatics perspective where we want
to identify tissue-specific expression
via some measure of skewness okay as I
mentioned before this kind of skid
profile suggests a tissue-specific perth
tissue specific nature as opposed to a
much broader expression okay and so from
a bioinformatics perspective the way we
chose to tackle this problem was to use
mixture modeling techniques okay so what
we did was we fitted mixture models
based on normal mixtures using equal
variance and this was done using the
m-class our package and the goal here
was to capture the shape of the
expression distribution using one or
more normally distributed components
okay in a perfect world we can imagine
that the number of tissue-specific
states in terms of gene expression is is
very distinct we may have 12 serene
different states and we can see them in
the distribution perfectly but the issue
here is that there is bleeding between
different states
for something we don't know how many
different gene expression states make
sense to describe this particular gene
so mixed remodeling tools give us the
flexibility of being able to anticipate
or estimate a different number of an
unknown number of mixtures or different
components so to give you more detail we
use these mixture models to fit
different components to the gene
expression distribution and the rule
that we had was if the critical regions
associated with each of these many
distributions overlapped then the genus
classified as ubiquitous meaning that
there's a broad gene expression
distribution that we're seeing otherwise
if the critical regions was so extreme
that was not overlap we consider that to
be a tissue-specific expression profile
now as you recall from basic statistics
the critical region is the rigid region
defined by usually half of the type 1
error rate so in this case we're using
point 05 or the critical region was to
find by the point 0 2 basically here and
so from our mixture model we can get
estimates of new 1 V 2 and Sigma as well
so what happens when we have more than
one more than 2 sorry adjacent mixtures
or mixtures in the genius Russian
distribution so in this case we've
extended our rule such that all critical
regions between any two adjacent
mixtures must be distinct the gene to
have a tissue-specific expression
profile and so this is just the
requirement that components all
components that have the potential to
overlap are extreme enough meaning the
states for the gene expression states
that their correspond to a distinct
enough for
Stream enough such that they don't
overlap okay so this was the rule that
we applied alongside the rule that we
use to determine tissue-specific
penetrance of the tumors and as a result
these are the chances eens that
segregate into the four classes that we
talked about so class one represents the
tissue specific treatments as well as
those jeans for tissue-specific
expression for class too these are the
genes that have ubiquitous streamers and
ubiquitous tissue expression gene
expression our for class three again
these are the most interesting genes
because they're tissue-specific in the
treatments that are affected but
ubiquitous in the gene expression that
we have said across the tissue atlas and
finally we have this kind of strange
group of genes which we haven't really
exploded all and these are the genes
that are known to be mutated in a large
range of tumors but are highly tissue
specific in terms of their gene
expression so first of all we wanted to
ask within these different groups of
genes what kind of functional roles are
enriched or shared within these classes
and so the first thing we did was to
look at ubiquitously expressed genes
versus tissue-specific expressed genes
and try to figure out what sort of
categories or roles in terms of cancer
and in general biological processes
these guys participating and one of the
most striking results of emerge from
this this analysis was that you because
of expressed genes are largely tumor
suppressor genes and the kind of
categories we see based on gene
enrichment was cell cycle DNA repair
cell adhesion type pathways and
processes on the other hand when we look
at tissue-specific expressed genes we
see that largely these are all crew
jeans and we see terms like
proliferation differentiation
migration and survival that are
significant for this group of genes and
what's also interesting is when we look
at our class three genes these the genes
that are tissue-specific and the team is
affected and ubiquitous in terms of gene
expression these are actually populated
with tumor suppressor genes so the next
area we wanted to look at was in terms
of the class three genes we wanted to
test others hypothesis that tissue
specific networks are actually working
to buffer the germline mutation genes in
a local now so we can imagine that for
our set of cancer resistant tissues we
had one particular network configuration
for Bracken one and for the susceptible
tissues like the breast and ovary
there's a different local network
structure that is regulating bracha one
in a normal situation in a normal
healthy tissue such that in the presence
of Ibaka one mutation this network is
affected differently such that
differences in susceptible tissue make
tissue more susceptible and differences
in the resistance as you may petition
water resistant so this is the
hypothesis that we wanted to test in our
local networks and what we did was we
use three different resources to
construct these networks so first of all
we looked heavily at protein-protein
interaction networks and the resource
that we used was I r EF index RF index
is a resource that combines
protein-protein interaction information
from multiple primary databases and it
does us really well in a non redundant
fashion so what you end up is
interactions that have been reported
across all the major protein-protein
interaction database
and you can access this using is our
which is an hour package that's very
easy to use we've also used a packet a
database called Tiger and this
represents tissue specific gene
expression and protein expression and
this comes from Johns Hopkins University
finally we've also used information from
thousand five where we've also used the
tissue specific levels of gene
expression to highlight which genes
which protein protein interactions are
relevant to a specific tissue okay so
the example that I've shown here also is
the networks that we've reconstructed
for Braca one and so it's a bit hard to
make out the individual gene components
but the point of this is that we have a
protein-protein interaction network for
the breast on the right and the central
protein here is Rocco one so everything
is centered around Rocco on and on the
left we have the protocol trash network
for there an example of a resistant
tissue which in this case of small
intestine and basically can see that
there's some differences in the
highlighting between or the shading
between different networks so red
indicates presence or absence of this
protein and there's some others in terms
of the size of the nodes in terms of
levels of gene expression and how they
differ from different tissues that those
are quite difficult to see in the
graphics or we won't go into that too
much at all but another way to look at
this which is better in terms of just
eyeballing a more quantitative way to
look at this would be to start looking
at properties of the network so for
instance we can look at connectivity for
the degree distribution associated with
each of these protein-protein
interaction networks so what we've shown
here is the degree distribution for
Braca one this represents the number of
protein-protein interactions for Braca
one
in each of the different tissues and so
oh and so each other lines the red line
represents data that's been used from
those tiger and phantom fire and then
the blue and the black line represents
using only one of these resources so
phantom 5 and tiger respectively but the
point of this diagram is to show you
that across the different tissue classes
that we're looking at there are some
differences in connectivity for brachle
one in normal tissue and so but overall
we see that there is actually a lot of
consistency apparent so what I've
highlighted here with these yellow bars
is the ovary on the left and on the
right the regular bar corresponds to the
breast network and you can see that for
these guys there is some differences to
other tissues like stomach and
intestines and the green bars in this
situation highlight the network that's
been built for cancer samples that we
had available and so on the far left we
have the breast cancer sample and on the
far right we have the ovarian cancer
sample and you can see that so these are
for tissue networks that we've
highlighted the connectivity is actually
virtually identical so there aren't any
obvious differences here for these
cancer and tissue specific networks for
the tissues of interest but it could be
that there are other differences in the
network that we've yet to really fully
explore so what we've also done is to
look at the rock or one protein-protein
interaction network from a functional
perspective and so all I've done is
we've looked at enrichment of particular
pathways or biological processes of the
genes that have been annotated to these
protein-protein interaction networks now
we know that bracket one participates in
DNA damage response
damage repair so it's probably not a
huge surprise that when we look at
functional enrichment we see terms
relating to double-stranded break
repairs and and miss ranch repairs um
when we look at these networks we see
that breast ovarian tissue specific
networks similar to each other as we've
put it out on the previous graph and
there are actually more similar to
networks that represent the scene as a
meninges they're actually the most
distinct from tissue specific networks
that come from the stomach and bone so
we're exploring some of the more we're
exploring this result in detail and so
this raises the question overall in
terms of whether differences in DNA
damage pathways are being used in normal
tissues to determine resistance or
susceptibility to cancer and now when
you think about this from just a common
sense perspective it makes a lot of
sense different tissues in the body as
accepted subjected to different levels
of DNA damage whether it's at a basal
rate whether it's a turnover rate that's
different from one tissue to another or
whether other tissues are certain
tissues are exposed to different
environmental exposures or toxin
exposures it makes sense that different
tissues are lyrics are dependent on DNA
damage pathways in at a different level
okay and so from these results for
starting to think whether these
differences in DNA damage pathways are
actually setting up this buffering
capability of genes in the presence of
the germline mutation so what we also
wanted to do was identify key components
of the bracket one network in terms of
looking just straight at different
Connie
there wasn't an obvious difference but
what we wanted to do was look at
differential expression between Braca
one interactors between susceptible and
resistant tissues and so what we did
here was we highlighted genes in the
back of one protein-protein interaction
network that were differentially
expressed between resistant and
susceptible tissues and also those that
were highly connected so we took a
threshold of ten of the proteins that
were reported and what we did was we
found some interesting genes that
represented cyclones kinases genes that
were involved in DNA binding and when we
looked at enrichment of functional
categories in this group they
recapitulated the functional categories
that we saw before when we looked at the
entire Braca one protein-protein
interaction network and some of these
examples are actually quite interesting
from a cancer genetics perspective some
of them are listed here and we're going
to be following up with them in more
detail as well so we've also looked a
transcription factor regulatory networks
as well and we using Maura a method or
rather were using an output from Mara
which is a method for Network
reconstruction that's been developed by
our phantom five collaborators and so
here we've used the transcription factor
networks that they have constructed for
bracket one and we've looked at this
network in different tissues um you can
see that there is actually a lot more
diversity that's observed in the network
kept connectivity for bracket one and so
we're starting to look at what some of
those differences are again and more
detail this is a result that we've only
just recently got one thing that we've
also done is to extend the predictions
that we've made for the cancer genes
with germline mutations and extend this
to the rest of the gene
in genome and so basically we can make
predictions into what genes fall into
the four classes that we delineate in
using the classifier we develop the gene
expression and also the tissue-specific
penetrance classifier we developed for
data in cosmic and as a result you can
see that these are the different numbers
that fall into these different classes
and the reason why this is valuable oh
hang on let me just go through some of
these are the results so when we look at
these numbers don't really mean much but
when we look at what genes are actually
falling into each of these classes what
we see in terms of function regiment is
again the presence of tumor suppressors
and she was suppress the categories or
categories associated with tumor
suppression activity that are occurring
in our class three genes another thing
that's worth mentioning is that other
significant terms are occurring in class
three that suggests other BOTS buffering
mechanisms for instance ubiquitination
so these predictions are putative they
haven't been experimental evaluation but
there isn't one interesting and could be
a value is that they represent classes
and jeans to target or investigate in
the case of the tissue specific cancer
particularly if not a lot is known about
the genetics of that in that Pacific
tissue okay so we'll put those lists out
there soon okay I'm running into
question time now so I just wanted to
wrap up my presentation by going over
some of the conclusions that we've been
able to make so far now just to remind
you the goal is to understand why
resistant issues are able to buffer a
germline mutation that under in
susceptible tissues we look for clues in
tissue specific networks in normal
tissue to understand how regulation is
occurring
differently and how this might lead to
susceptibility in resistance we
identified a set of class three genes
these are genes that had broad
expression across the tissue atlas and
we're associated with highly
tissue-specific humans now these are
candidates for looking at local network
changes and normal tissue to try and
understand how these network changes are
contributing to cancer susceptibility
for Braca one the evidence was seeing is
that DNA damage pathways may be in the
distinguishing factor between resistance
and susceptible tissues we've also
identified differentially expressed and
highly connected nodes in the
protein-protein interaction networks for
brachle one that may be candidates for
specifically driving this distinction
and so I just wanted to end there by
acknowledging some of the collaborators
that we work with we've been working
with the ricans omics science center
yokohama specifically with dr. al forest
and dr. ma'kelda hoon they've been a
wonderful support in terms of providing
access to this resource and help along
the way with this project and finally
I'd like to thank my post doc dr. Dani
Pedrosa acabar producer who has been the
main driver behind all this work that I
presented today so the final and I'd
like to thank all of you for tuning in
to my presentation and i'm just going to
switch over right now to take questions
so we have our first question from Ezra
thank you as IFAs emitting this question
and as I says what is the percentage of
epigenetic markers such as histone
modification or methylation and
tissue-specific penetrants for the
bracha one gene did you check both of
them on bracket one that's a fantastic
question
unfortunately with the resources
available we didn't have the ability to
look at epigenetic regulation certainly
that would be something of interest due
to the epigenetic nature of tissue
specific differences so it I can talk to
your question because we didn't check
them from rakha one but that's something
that would have been really interesting
if we could are there any more questions
from the audience I if that's the case
then I'd like to wrap up by thanking
everyone for your participation and I'd
also like to thank the organizers of the
bio conference live it's been really
great to be able to share my research
with you today so thank you very much